[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
q a number 88
we are here streaming on both youtube
and odyssey and we are going to answer
your questions with our
brand new question accumulation
program specially designed for dark
horse
that's right once again that's um
darkhorsesubmissions.com that's where
you'll find it
um you know when we first started doing
these live streams in march of 2020 we
because it was uh this was during the
school year and our producer
was the then then 15 year old
uh zachary weinstein our son i know it
seems like it can't be right but it must
be because it was just before
his 16th birthday and he's now 17. um
we did them even though he was in
virtual school at that point but we had
to do them after school was over
and so we always start at 3 30 and uh
these last couple of times that we've
started at three just seem
completely exhausting because you've
just you've had a day before you do this
so
we're a little we're a little punchy
like we were i think last week for the
questions
um i mean it's also been a hard week
yeah because of mine but it has
um so we're gonna we're gonna do our
best here guys
all right yeah um so we're gonna start
with a question from the discord server
this week every week
uh people on discord get together and
decide on what question they most want
to ask and uh we start there and
the most discordant question i don't
know if it's like that
well i don't know i don't know we'll see
discordy
discordy
um terrestrial vertebrates
yes that's the question no terrestrial
vertebrates are all tetrapods
four legged but terrestrial
invertebrates can have six eight ten or
more
what is it about having an internal
skeleton that limited ancestral
terrestrial vertebrates
vertebrates to evolving only for lambs
so that's i i love this question um and
i
um i ki i have sort of a kind of a
mechanistic answer
and i'm not sure i i feel like i would
like to spend
a week or so talking with people about
this rather than trying to do something
kind of
kind of off the top of my head what are
you looking for well i'm thinking back
through the phylogeny and trying to
figure out how much we're going to foist
off onto historical constraint and how
much we've got a mechanistic
reason they're they look like they're
they sound like they're looking for a
mechanistic explanation i'm just trying
to
well one one of the levels of mechanism
has to do with hox genes yep um so this
is this
big class of of genes called homeobox
genes within which
um is a category of genes called hox
genes sometimes those are conflated
actually often they're complete in fact
i found a paper by two
well-respected uh biologists today in
which they you know often
say like hawks parentheses homeobox or
the universe but no like hawks is a
subset of homeobox and hox genes
specifically
are involved in basically um
repeating segments on the anterior
posterior axis
and so in invertebrates you basically
have an axial skeleton an
axis sort of three skeletons
developmentally you've got an axial
skeleton
a cranial skeleton and then an
appendicular skeleton the
up the appendices um and
exactly as the discord people are are
positing
we've got two girdles we've got two
appendicular
um girdles the pectoral girdle up here
off which come our arms and the pelvic
girdle off which come our legs
and that's actually highly conserved
across
all
all vertebrates um there are no you
when you get repeats when you get um
repeats that don't belong in the hogs
genes invertebrates
um at the you know sort of appendicular
girdle level
um those those hopeful monsters don't
survive
right they aren't they aren't that
hopeful um
but there it does seem to me that
there's something about the um
the the more repeats that are already in
the arthropod skeleton i don't know if
it's going to be an internal versus
external skeleton thing per se
but the fact that there are just already
more repeats um
and so this sort of you know at each at
each of the segments
off an arthropod skeleton um you can
kind of do a repeat that involves legs
um
or or not and
you know so there i sort of fizzle out
without having spent a lot more time
digging back into the
evo devo stuff that i once kind of knew
but also i think we don't fully
understand
you know like the anterior posterior
axis hox genes deal with repeats
but you know what more than that yeah um
i have to say i don't have a good fix on
this there is something about
the arthropods with their many segments
that there are bound to be
simple rules for animating those
segments yeah in other words simple
patterns and in fact
those of us who have experimented with
robot building
find that you can you know you can
create uh
an insect or a spider and that you know
it's not so hard to figure out a pattern
that actually produces locomotion
yeah um and there's something about
the fact of the vertebrates being
more software flexible
so the pattern that functions to produce
locomotion
is something that can be partially
acquired now obviously a horse locomotes
pretty well at birth
a person does not so how much
flexibility there needs to be is a
question but i'm wondering
about so you're you're talking it's like
a conservation of flexibility
like if invertebrates which tend to have
more software control
um there might be less flexibility
in the hardware side in this case the
hawks genes
it's a lot easier to produce a
vertebrate that cannot figure out how to
walk
rather than you know i'm thinking by
analogy
um i think i pointed some weeks ago to
vi hearts
analysis of fibonacci sequences in
plants and the basic point was nowhere
in the plants is there a description of
a
fibonacci sequence what there is is a
set of simple rules that results in
fibonacci sequences
that basically serve to get the leaves
out of each other's shadow so as you
change the form of a plant
you get a slight modification of where
the leaves come out but basically they
are repelled
they are chemically repelled from the
last from all the other leaves in such a
way that distributes them so that they
fill in whatever structure you've gotten
so the basic point is
you've got a system that as you change
the structure of a plant
distributes the leaves in some useful
way and i'm imagining that there might
be something similar
where as you add legs
there's some mechanism for figuring out
how to
coordinate them and that this would be
much harder to do
in vertebrates therefore
a conservation where the way to locomote
is a variation on a known theme yeah
rather than
a rapidly expanding combinatorics
problem
yeah it might be the well there's also
it's it's very rare invertebrates
um to be able to regenerate limbs or
digits it's
it it is it exists in some in
i think a couple of different salamander
clades in fact
had yes so for sure one salamander clay
but i think it's actually more than one
salamander clade so actually
multiple i think the evidence suggests
i'm recalling correctly well i i think
there may be multiple evolutions of
of this capacity but it is it is
restricted to i think caudates to
salamanders within
um at least within the tetrapods and i
think maybe within the vertebrates more
broadly whereas
um
everything about arthropods seems sort
of more segmented
like you know you everyone has seen like
harvest men which aren't spiders but are
related to spiders
daddy long legs um having lost a leg and
still moving around fine sometimes
us three four or five legs even right
then they still do fine they don't you
know there's no need to staunch the
bleeding they just like it happens
and vertebrates don't do nearly as good
a job of sealing off
things when they lose it when they lose
something well there's a question about
where this comes from though because um
[Music]
so we have noticed many times in the
tropics when you're when you're at a
field station that has some sort of
lights that stay on all night they
act as an inadvertent light trap and so
especially if you
lodge somewhere where you pass the same
wall every night you get a kind of a
sense of
who's coming out of the forest and it's
amazing how frequently
you encounter animals that are missing a
limb and still functioning
but it's all insects and attractants
right
but the point is all right these are
creatures that don't have
meaningful capacity for repair at all
right and so there's a question what
does selection
see when you know a spider has lost a
limb right
it has no process by which to give up
and fairly frequently
a spider who has lost a limb and manages
will reproduce
so but that cap maybe it's capacity for
a pair that is the the sort of causal
agent that we're looking for rather than
external versus internal skeleton
that's exactly where i was going my
point is going to be
in the vertebrates we see the repair
capacity
tracking the viability of the creature
in repair and post repair so we see it i
think we've mentioned this
recently we see it in things like sloths
which fall out of trees and break a limb
and because they're not just a tree limb
right
they because their ecology
does not depend on them dodging
predators
through stealth or through speed um
you can actually get away with being a a
a sloth with a bum limb and survive
through crypsis which is the basic way
that they avoid being eaten
so the point is there have been lots and
lots of sloths that have broken a limb
and then gone on to reproduce so there's
lots of capacity to repair
monkeys similarly and us right we have
lots of capacity for that kind of repair
but loss of limb how often
and so the point is why is this capacity
not augmented
the capacity to replace a limb i see
one of two paths one limb loss is so
devastating that you don't tend to
survive
it and leave offspring in the ancestral
environment
and the other which leans more in the
direction of my initial response here
is that we have to learn to use our
limbs
and so if you replaced a limb it's not
automatically clear that it would be so
useful just the same way as a blind
person who's been blind since birth
who suddenly gets sight doesn't
necessarily know what to do with the
information that there's
that's coming in their eyes because they
didn't go through the developmental
process that would teach them how to
deal with it so you know is the reason
that we can't regenerate our limbs
because
it's biologically impossible to create
that
or is it that it just has not been
useful so in the same way that a horse
doesn't have the capacity to
repair a broken leg very easily because
very few horses in the ancestral past
ever survived a broken leg because they
would get picked off by whatever
predators were present
it just never got augmented yeah and i
guess so not appendicular skeleton but
returning to axial skeleton
limb regeneration is very rare and let's
just
stick to tetrapods because i'm just less
sure about the um aquatic vertebrates
the the primarily aquatic vertebrates
ones that didn't return secondarily
but along the axial skeleton caudal
autotomy
which is fancy language for um tail loss
and regrowth
is actually fairly common in the um
in the squamates right which is the
lizards and and
snakes um where and in fact they're
they're definitely in this case
different
evolutions of caudal autonomy because in
some cases it's inter-vertebral
in some cases the when a predator bites
the tail
it's adaptively advantageous to drop the
tail and they'll leave
leave the tail moving while you escape
and the predator's got a mouthful a tail
sometimes that break happens between the
vertebrae intervertebrally and sometimes
it's intravertibly
sometimes it's actually it breaks a
vertebra in half
yep really um so you know clearly
different
different evolutions of of caudal
autonomy which
um if you're if you're a yummy little
lizard um or a snake
uh there are there are apparently many
clades in which
um that was an adaptive all right thank
you
my ignorance is about to come to the
surface here i uh would have said that
there are no snakes that have caudal
autonomy are you telling me that there
are any yeah as i was saying i was like
i think they're i think they're safe but
i'm not i'm not positive
and you know why so i i have this
i have a sense of like why there might
not be you probably have a sense of why
that might are you just saying i've
never seen it
yeah uh my sense is locomotory wise
it you know loss of a tail um is a big
deal no matter who you are if you had a
tail
yeah um but for a snake it's an even
bigger deal because you're using
um you know depending there's like these
five modes of locomotion and snakes but
regardless you're using your body on the
ground to some degree and your tail is
part of that body on the ground and so
yeah
lose your tail and you may actually be
be really incapable of getting around
for a while after that
yeah although you could grapple i mean i
don't see any reason that it shouldn't
work but i think
the reason i guess i'm not expecting it
is the way snakes are preyed upon may
not make it all that
useful right in other words if you're
jumping at a lizard and the lizard is
escaping
it's not uncommon that you end up with
its tail
and it drops the tail and i'm thinking
that might not be the case with snakes
at the way
a predator goes after a snake a very
quick search reveals the russian journal
of herpetology
from 1994
uh caudal autotomy and the kluberd snake
xenocrophis piscotator
no pisskater from vietnam uh the
abstract
uh which is not extensive a rare case of
caudal autonomy including snake
from vietnam is described it is an
intervertebral autonomy that differs
from the more commonly encountered
intravertebral autonomy typical of most
lizard species
distribution and origin of
intervertebral autonomy and squamates
are discussed so
does it say anything there about some
predator that would
then validate the uh trickier part of
the hypothesis i just put forward
um yeah i i do not have the rights to
the full
uh paper at the russian journal of
herpetology i'll have to you know try to
cy hub this later or something
so at the moment i'll have these
abstract abstracting the references all
you
have is the abstract which which is like
two sentences
you rush into conclusions which in a
scientific paper
are up front in the abstract
they are yes russian yep conclusions
i'm right there got it got it got it
not overwhelmed with the humor but not
no a rough week
yeah yeah um
question one from this week i've been a
liberal my whole life
my father now thinks i'm a right-wing
nut job and is unwilling to even listen
to your podcast
there's obviously a lot of information
he hasn't been exposed to how do i help
him in the right way
this has been a process for me and has
changed my life
yeah that's a good one and the most
important part of it has to do with the
family aspect i think a lot of us
are finding this um i know that i am
finding it even
pretty close in uh within not
family so much but friend group where
people that you would imagine should see
at least the confusion of where we are
and should understand that
somebody arriving at a conclusion that
sounds like it's from the other side
isn't
on the other side they've just followed
the evidence somewhere
[Music]
i think the thing that i would start
with
is the evidence that nobody
really knows what's going on is pretty
profound and i would point to the
following thing people
are sick with a lot of different things
right whether it's obesity
or autism or anxiety
disorders right the number of maladies
that afflict human beings is many
and lots of people are willing to tell
you that x malady is not
caused by y influence
what they're not willing to do is tell
you what it is caused by so the basic
point is
nobody wants to address the sheer number
of places where we have apparently done
something wrong enough
to harm thousands hundreds of thousands
sometimes millions of people
and that in such an environment the last
thing you want to do
is shut down
lines of inquiry that proceed from
evidence
to testable conclusions and so i don't
know that there's any way to get
your father was it to pay attention to
the dark horse podcast or it's
necessarily the thing
that would open their eyes but i think
what people need
to realize is that the voice that is
assuring them that things are pretty
good and
that those crazy ideas on the fringe are
really not worth paying attention to
none of these people are in a position
to explain
why we're so you know
unwell as a species that's not something
if you go into nature look at any
species in nature
you do not see a huge amount of
unwellness
creatures tend to be well adapted to our
to their environments we are very poorly
adapted to this one and has a lot to do
with the fact that we've introduced a
lot of noise
naively into these places and have no
idea what the consequences are so really
who is anybody to shut down anybody
who's at least doing the work honestly
yeah um
you know i think uh for a lot of
lifelong
liberals especially of a certain age
the idea of a podcast is also
just this just you're just not gonna
open that door
um and both both brett and i you know
write as well and you know many people
do and i'm at the moment not
you know like you know find the right
piece
by one of us you know i'm thinking your
recent unheard piece just is clearly
from the left the piece that i had
published an area a while back what if
we're wrong
our book but you know if if our names
are at this point
somehow sullied which is absurd but i
know it's true in some circles
try finding you know something from at
taibi or
glenn greenwald um or barry weiss those
are just the three names that pop up
most you know most obviously people
with you know big sub stacks um
you know the first two are definitely uh
coming from the left
and you know just saying i'm like you
know like like we are like
gotta clean my own house first right
like you know the critique
is you know from the left and of the
left
uh because because we see the failures
of um what was supposed to be our people
most acutely
yeah i think you know last thing on this
topic maybe
i've tried to come up with some
formulations that cause
one to have to engage them consciously
here
and i think the idea you know these are
just
me surfacing things that are
underlying here before you ever get
around to naming it
reluctant radical right
to be unashamed to be a radical but to
acknowledge
that being a radical is not a good idea
it's something one only
does if one doesn't have a choice i
think
it doesn't take very much looking around
the world to realize
things are off and it's not a big
extrapolation from there
that we have to change and we have to
change is not a happy message because
change is dangerous
so you know can you say to somebody look
this person
is you know unashamed
of being on the left and not only on the
left but
deeply enough progressive to accept the
term radical which is not a nice term at
the moment nobody
nobody's proud of being a radical at the
moment and the point is reluctant
radical
is the answer it says you know that this
is a position
arrived at cautiously and not
uh not politically frankly so
sorry i think we have elephants in the
front yard at the moment
[Music]
the copper here uh next question
as a nurse i often work with people who
have dementia
these people don't control their
impulses well they don't mind being
offensive
this lack of inhibitions coupled with
their age might make you think that they
would be highly racist
as is often portrayed in pop culture yet
in my experience
racist dementia patients are much rarer
than you might think many having warm
reports
uh rapport with staff members of color
is this an argument against the idea
that we are all inherently racist
yes 100 and this also matches what we
have
been saying which is that it's very rare
to encounter
you know it's not rare to encounter
ignorance in fact it's more often than
not
right even in oneself if you do a survey
of your own
understanding you will find ignorance in
yourself if you compare it to the world
that is not the same thing as bigotry
right it is willful ignorance that
is the you know the beginning of bigotry
and the desire
for one race to win out over others and
the fact is the desire to remain
ignorant
right that's the beautiful part okay
yeah um
and the point is that's just not common
i think
most people have actually gotten
to the first layer of
the cosmopolitan stack where we've
recognized you know what
everything is better when you stop
rooting for a phenotype
yeah right i mean starting with lunch
lunch is so much better when you can go
out and have a falafel and not think too
much about
the political implications of it because
it just tastes good right
you know everything is like that the
ability yep
to break bread with somebody who
a hundred years ago might have been
viewed as an opposing
team and to learn how the world looks
from through their
eyes and uh to just experience the
camaraderie of it
it's just so much freaking better and
everybody knows this right there's a
reason
that you know as silly as it was the
united colors of benetton
resonated with people
right and you know i'd like to buy the
world of coke like that's what you want
to buy the world but
the point was i mean seriously
yes these are garbage versions but what
they are is
proof positive that the advertising
people who are completely amoral
right they're willing to use our
internal circuitry against us
these people have tapped into the fact
that people don't want to be racist they
want to see themselves
as welcoming and open and whether or not
they're any good
at it the point is it's still not you
rooting for your
people against other people the world is
just better when we don't do that
and everybody knows it and yes there are
a few [ __ ] outliers but
god damn it right ignorance is common
that
over or even covert racism thing is not
common anymore
so all right awesome that was great
that's awesome
next question totally different how
would evolutionary biology explain why
younger humans are better protected
against covet than older
seems paradoxical regarding with regard
to adaptive immunity something else
going on besides
innate immunity no i think
i think well probably something else is
going on but
there are two questions yeah and they
are separable
one is how likely you are
to contract covid given the same
exposure as somebody else
that's liable to be an innate immunity
question
almost entirely how sick do you get how
well do you tolerate covid
could be more complex it could be you
know there's a lot of
stuff involved in physiology and a lot
of it gets less effective with age and
there are certainly diseases
that impact the young more than the old
and there are diseases that go the other
way
so but are are both things true like we
know we've talked about
many times um how much less sick
children and young people tend to get
when they get coveted but i'm not i
don't actually know
off the top of my head if given the same
exposures
if a five-year-old a 15-year-old a
45-year-old and a 75-year-old
are differently likely to get sick i
think we don't have
a certain answer to that question and
the problem in part
is that for no reason i can think of
we have still a terrible mechanism for
testing and
no concerted effort we're kind of not
doing it anyway right right
if we were smart as you and i have been
saying since the very beginning
if we were smart we would have test
populations in which we
surveyed everybody regularly so we would
have some idea how this thing actually
spreads but the problem is when we test
you because you've come
come down with something that's made you
sick
what we do is we bias the sample against
the discovery that you have the disease
and haven't
become sick which means the answer could
be anything
because we know that young people get
sick less severely that also presumably
means that to the extent that there are
cases more missing cases there's more
missing cases so you don't know the
answer and
you know that we don't know the answer
that's one thing that's why we don't
know the answer
is quite another that is and that we're
moving over like the
the media and the talking medical heads
are acting like uh we've got good data
right
is i mean it's a lie that has
deep medical uh effects yes and
the fact that the justification
for vaccinating young people is is
predicated on
one answer and not the other right you
wouldn't vaccinate people who weren't
going to come down with it so there's
almost the assumption
that they must be coming down with it
and transmitting it right
and maybe they are but i i don't think
but there's no excuse
for not having a really good answer to
that question and a really good answer
to that question involves two things
it involves a good reliable test and
it involves applying it to a population
enough that you can detect
what the actual endogenous rate is
indeed
hi i'm 28 years old male from holland
healthy not overweight
no underlying health problems or
allergies that i'm aware of
i got my first shot of pfizer then i
heard you live stream with gert
vandenbush
now i am doubting to get my second shot
yes or no any opinions or advice
can't give you advice first off yeah
always
always have to my god it's busy here
today there's a lot of elephants coming
down the driveway
um yeah we
we're not medical doctors and we can't
provide advice
um but the more i've been thinking
about um the vaccines that involve
two shots um the more
it feels to me like if you've had the
one you should get the second
so that you don't have partial immunity
well
boy i wish we knew the answer to the
question um i mean given that you're
gonna have partial immunity in
six months anyway like like i think i
think the
answer is unfortunately you've been left
in a
uh you have been
left blind in multiple regards
and how protected you are
we don't know what you are comparing it
to even we don't know
from your question and we can't give you
advice anyway
so sorry i mean
there's not much to say
well i was trying to answer a more
general question
um we don't know right okay
why are we advised to sleep in a
completely dark and silent room
if our ancestors were likely sleeping
under moonlight and starlight amidst the
sounds of weather and animal tomfoolery
and among snaring kin
i like animal tomfoolery yeah this is a
this is a
great question um the
so and i i think we can take these
separately dark and silent
so let's go with silent first which is
kind of the easier one um
and let's take it to its um sort of it's
the the even simpler one which is like
oh don't make a noise the baby is
sleeping
okay if you never make a noise when your
baby is sleeping
you're going to make a child that can
never sleep when there's noise like
that actually should should be obvious
and the idea that everyone has to
literally tiptoe around the sleeping
baby
um so that right in this moment the baby
doesn't wake up and make you have to you
know
dandelion a little bit more or whatever
it is is extraordinarily short-sighted
so you know do what you're going to do
around the baby and you're going to end
up with
a young child and then an older child
then a young adult and then an adult
who is actually able to sleep through
more disturbance and is actually able to
um you know be probably less anxious as
well so that's
one thing yeah um anecdotally i will
also say
um our kids shared a room for a very
long time
mm-hmm yeah once they were out of our
room they went they were in there shared
a room and you know it was a nice
big room and they had lots of other
space so
it wasn't like they were corralled
together or really much but they
you know they were sleeping in the same
room and i also would point out as
you've mentioned before
you know there's almost not been an
instance where either one of them has
gotten up you know out of bed after
having gone to sleep
you know it's not been a common
occurrence the way i remember it being a
common occurrence in my life when i was
a
little kid right i i got out of bed
because i couldn't sleep or
things were bugging me or whatever and i
would just say
i think part of this is that each of
them got used to sleeping in some
situation that was more normal which was
there were people around and so
you weren't constantly woken up by the
slightest disturbance because
disturbance was just something you
accept and you know i also used to
teach a lesson um back when we were
teaching at evergreen
about the fact that the brain is clearly
processing
the content of auditory information that
somebody who lives near the elevated
train and the train goes by
and doesn't wake them may wake when they
hear somebody turn the doorknob
if there shouldn't be anybody turning
the doorknob that's right so there's
some part of you that's paying attention
and calibrates
what is worth waking you up for and so
if it's calibrated to an environment
yeah stuff's going on but it's you know
not critical yeah right you get used to
it and
there is something about our you know
way of
isolating ourselves that i think
probably does make
nervous sleepers absolutely um so
with regard to light i mean i think
maybe we'll just save that
we're going to be talking about sleep a
lot on this next saturday because it's
the sleep chapter of the book that we'll
be talking about but
um this very short
two very short aspects of the answer are
most of the light
that we generate that humans make um is
it a different wavelength and a
different lux
different intensity than anything we
would normally be exposed to
um and then excuse me
um people tend to actually sleep
less people outside of of structures
tend to sleep
less when the moon is fuller suggesting
that not only do we have seasonal
changes in our circadian patterns but we
have
lunar changes in our circadian patterns
and that the more light there is in the
sky the less we're sleeping
[Music]
yep
i don't i okay i'm gonna read the
question but i'm not sure that i can
i'm not sure i can do a good job with
this one at the moment can you please
discuss
absolute risk reduction versus relative
risk reduction both for the code
vaccines and ivermectin
are we comparing the same for both
um in light of the current environment
i want to brush up on this before i say
anything because you and i are now
being exposed to a standard that i think
is rather
ridiculous for podcasts but um
i think we have to hold off on that yeah
and i think let's say it's the second
part
i we are not comparing anything fairly
there's a double standard
yeah i mean i guess that's like i can't
even
as i'm trying to think back
on the many papers that you know we're
seeing
like a the you know the papers on
vaccines aren't really even
papers by and large it's like you know
data coming out of theirs and like a
very occasion there's papers but it's
it's not analyzing the same way and by
and large it's not the same
it's not the same kinds of assessments
so you know what
how how can we actually compare them i'm
not
well they're certainly comparable if you
wanted to organize that but i mean
given the data that we have i'm not yes
it would be possible but i don't know
how if you don't have access to the
actual data how you can use the you know
just the
papers that have been written um to to
get at the more fundamental analysis
that i think does need to be done
yep so it's a good question i wish we
had the answer
um i remember this one from last week um
i thought we might have answered it or
maybe we saved it for the next for this
time so you tell me if we address this
or not
okay how do you travel with the saphir
vu um
should i start over yes yeah how do you
travel with a severe
food allergy especially with a language
barrier uh we did not answer we did not
do that one
no um yeah
uh i mean i think it depends on what the
allergy is and where you are yeah where
you are right
so you know if you've got a dairy
allergy and you're traveling in east
asia
you're um you're likely to be okay and
you know you learn
you know you you learn the words for the
things that you are very very allergic
to and as many of the permutations of
those words as you can
for sure and you be very gracious and
apologetic for not having mastery of the
language and you
ask about it um but you know it's also
true that for instance
in you know in latin america you have a
strong dietary problem with
wheat and there are lots of ways to say
wheat and gluten
and flour and sometimes when people say
flour they mean corn flour which you
don't have a problem with and sometimes
they don't understand that something
that's been breaded is actually you know
got flour in it and so
you know in in a culture where the thing
that you're allergic to
is prevalent and sometimes cryptic it
can be
tough yeah um in latin america
virtually the only thing that works
is to limit one's diet
consciously to those things that one can
be pretty sure
aren't going to be polluted with wheat
in my case
which is unpleasant because there's lots
of other stuff you could potentially eat
but it's very hard to ask the question
and our experience is that there's not a
lot of recognition
that there is a problem with wheat so
when you start asking is there wheat in
this people don't even really know it
seems like a gringo problem
right yeah it's a gringo problem yeah um
in italy we ran into the situation where
the the cuisine is so heavily wheat
based
and there's just kind of no you know we
did
i've heard actually that in parts of
italy it's quite easy to get like
gluten-free pizza and gluten-free pasta
but we were we just were lucky enough to
be in venice for
a week or so two summers ago yeah it was
it was basically non-existent
yeah we had a lot of gelato which was
not bad yeah it's not bad
and uh and campari gelato
we had one experience the first first
night we were there we were trying to
figure out how to navigate the uh
the wheat thing and we happened to have
a waiter who was
fluent in english and at some point we
had
ended the meal and he wanted to know if
we wanted
you know dessert and one of the things
for dessert was the cheese plate
and uh we tried to order it and he got
very protective of us
because uh i wouldn't have been able to
have the bread and
that would just isn't done right that
was that was actually an earlier trip
that was actually paris
that was a that was
but anyway yeah it's a it's a huge
problem and the
the thing in any place where people
aren't sensitive to this
the cost of an error just does not dawn
on them as
you know because some people avoid weed
because they think they have an issue
and some of us have an issue that it's
you know i got uh i got a
i ordered a gluten-free hamburger brown
on a hamburger in new york several weeks
ago
and uh halfway through the burger
the waitress came out very apologetic
they had given me the wrong
one and there was nothing to be done
about it at that point
and i suffered for it for a couple weeks
i've just now finally gotten over
the cough that it gives me is one of its
symptoms
um so anyway that's a big you know
that's a couple weeks
of life being substantially compromised
but anyway yeah i don't think there's a
great answer it's not a great answer um
you know it really it
depending on what the allergy is and
what the
cuisine is like where you are um
you know it might be easy and it might
be very hard
yeah um and you know regardless you know
with the language barrier is real
and you know we basically have it
everywhere we go that um is not english
speaking even though we can you know
we can get by you always want to learn
um
enough of whatever the local language is
um to be polite and to have your basic
formulations but specifically if you've
got a food allergy to learn as many of
the permutations of the word that that
might be referred to as
so that you can recognize it on a menu
so you can say a bunch of different
things
to you know a waiter and you know
especially if your accent is bad
so that you might hit something at some
point that they're like oh yeah actually
i do know what you're talking about now
right um we'll say what there's another
problem
there's really nothing you can do about
which is that even if you
get the word right some part of the way
we process
language basically limits the vocabulary
based on how much you think the person
you're talking to
knows yes yes right and so to the extent
that you're saying you know does this
have wheat in it and that's a question
they're not expecting something yeah
like this guy doesn't know how to say
man and he can say wheat i don't think
so right so
uh anyway yeah it's tough
um you know it might even be worth
printing something up that has the
question
right so that you've got the question
phrased and the explanation of
why it matters yeah um you might get a
higher quality answer
in fact i might try that yeah
given the infuriating nature of what's
going on with covid and ivermectin what
advice can you give to avoid becoming
cynical about humanity's fate
um i'm going to give you some different
advice
i would become cynical no you wouldn't
yes i would i would become cynical
i would spend maybe a week there
and then come out the other side you
really you you're going to need if you
spend your life trying to avoid falling
into that bit of cynicism it's going to
haunt you if you
look into the abyss get used to it and
then you say okay
it's going to be a tough fight how are
we going to address this
you come out the other side i think i
think you'll be happier i think people
do
make a mistake of spending way too much
time trying not to fall into cynicism
rather than just like you know pulling
them back and realize that it sucks
and emerge that it's not useful yeah
right it's counterproductive
so okay enjoy it take take a week off of
being hopeful enjoy it and then come out
the other side and
rejoin the fight okay how's that for
counter-intuitive
yeah i wasn't expecting that okay uh
this is a proposal for a variant
of [ __ ] mary kill uh
which is a framing for what you might do
with a
person that you encounter who's a
stranger i think what
i i i believe okay so
um
no it's a choice it's not it's not a
sequence okay
um so the proposed alternative
yes you are uh the alternative
that uh hippopotamus rex here uh
proposes
is eat fight kipa's pet
and the the cat the the representatives
of each category that hippopotamus rex
proposes for eat
fight keep his pet are longhorn sheep
kangaroo
and ostrich now do people keep ostriches
as pets
i know they're not good to eat they're
eggs though
yeah i mean and wasn't there there's
some
no it was an emu war it wasn't an
ostrich or there's an emu war
uh back a while ago um i don't know
about people like keeping ostriches as
pets
i think they make poor pets um
[Music]
it was eat keep his pet fight to keep us
back
problems so kangaroo is the i don't
think fighting one is such a good idea
no
fight is the kangaroo eat fight keep his
pet
longhorn sheep kangaroo ostrich you have
to choose in each case
really yeah okay well i sort of thought
okay um i don't see a pet
option here then i mean
i could go for a tree kangaroo as a pet
that could be all right
a wallaby i believe a tree kangaroo is a
true kangaroo
well aren't i mean hmm i can't remember
i thought i thought um i thought
kangaroos and willowbees was a clade
uh macropods is gonna be the clade
kangaroos are actually
monophyletic they're separate boy am i
out of my depth here i don't know i
should know
i could probably end up with a bunch of
demerits as a
mammologist for not knowing whether
kangaroos is
uh monophyletic or i don't know i don't
know
okay um we're moving on
that didn't go well did it no it's fine
all right in theory could you overcome
both cancer and senescence by
continuously replacing broken parts the
same way cars
monuments etc are maintained over long
periods
monetary cost aside i think i think
we're actually back to the question from
the discord i think this is like the
arthropod
well response i'm not quite sure i'm not
quite sure what the hypothetical
is yes there is if you could externally
source parts and in fact this is an
example i
used to use in my senescence lecture
which is that
you know your car wouldn't get old
either if it came with a factory that
could always produce new parts right you
would just keep replacing them um so
that totally works
um the except i mean
it's an imperfect analogy uh for a
number of reasons one of which is that
uh you know your your engine
isn't reliant upon your radiator and
you know it needs it both those things
need to be present and functioning
but they don't they don't integrate with
one another in an ongoing
feedback-y way right well my use of that
in my old lecture on this topic was
about the paradox of aging
right so it was one piece of it right so
we seem to have a factory that makes new
parts
new cells we humans yeah we humans we
vertebrates etc
and yet we have this phenomenon and the
rate of aging
doesn't make sense with respect to
wearing out so for example
the fact that a human being
who you know goes to work in the fields
might last 80 years
and a cat who sleeps on the couch my
last 15 is
evidence that this isn't a question of
wearing out because you would imagine
that the person would wear out a lot
faster and yeah
in fact they don't and so there's
there's something interesting going on
there but
um yes in principle if you could replace
all the parts
um exogenously
then there's no reason that you have to
age i would point out though
but for the feedbacky stuff well but it
no it's the self-repairy stuff
the fact that it's endogenous that
causes the cancer risk which causes the
limits to have to be put on to keep the
runaway
repair stuff okay so my my butt for the
feedback
retort is there's a reason we can't just
outsource parts
that you know we're just barely
beginning to be able to do this with you
know things like
total joint replacements and such um but
there are
a lot of problems they require yeah
it requires a lot of work and it's still
really touch and go
well and there's a giant fly in the
ointment even if you were to figure this
one out which is the brain
right your brain is an informational
system and even if you could solve
its physiological aging problems you
cannot solve
through any known mechanism we
understand far too little about how it
even works
to know what to do with the fact that
your brain
is built to accumulate information and
forget
at a proper rate that you can live a
functional life of 80 90 years
and you would have to rewire it let's
say you were going to live 500 years or
if you eliminated the
endogenous tendency to age we know that
you might live a thousand years
that is to say if you extrapolate from a
human being on
the on the cusp of where
aging begins if you extrapolate from
their rate of death at that
moment just before getting to
uh 1200 years is something that would be
true for 50
of the population or something like that
but in any case if you did that then the
point is okay now you've got a brain
that is
wired to remember and forget
for a period of 80 years and
do you want to forget a huge amount more
in order to be able to
extend that process for a thousand years
right how do you reprogram the brain for
this and we just don't have the foggiest
notion
right
my dog passed away last monday the loss
is still keen
i often contemplated his mortality it
still did not prepare me
much love and thank you for giving moxie
a good life
thank you yeah thank you sort of wish i
knew more about the story because there
is a fair amount to say about
how to how to think about a pet's life
but
yeah don't know very much
um are you familiar with dr
eloquenogia i probably put you in that
name also aka dr k
from the healthy gamer community we'd
love to see you to discuss the evolution
of negative emotion addiction and
purpose
i don't know i don't know that name um
we do actually have a little section on
addiction in the
adulthood chapter the pen penultimate
chapter of the book
but it sounds like there's some there's
something deeper here than
where we go in that little section but
neither of us
are aware of him or her i assume him
it seems that those of us who are
unvaccinated so far are the bad guys now
how much of this is deserved
um i think we're being set up
to be the bad guys very clearly that's
in the messaging in fact it was trending
on
twitter uh pandemic of the unvaccinated
which is
incredibly obnoxious because even if you
want to say
that the unvaccinated have some role to
play in this obviously the vaccinated do
too
right because we've got a pandemic of
variance now
and the variants are very clearly
related
you know how they're related reasonable
people can disagree on that but
there does seem to be a tendency of
these vaccines to select for variants
that escape the protection generated by
the vaccines
so uh let's put it this way uh
whoever it is that is arguing that we
are not all in this together
they are the enemy we are in this
together we have a pandemic that none of
us
started right we have an obligation to
figure out how best to address it
when we have been hobbled with
incredibly bad
information and incredibly powerful
propaganda campaigns
and even to the extent that somebody on
this map
looks confused to you they're confused
right even if that's us if we are
confused we are honorably confused we
have no stake in this matter other than
wanting humanity to come through it as
well as possible
and we have demonstrated that time and
again so
look anybody who's portraying
somebody else here as the enemy unless
that somebody else was actually involved
in producing
this virus and even then if they
produced it
as an accident there is no reason to be
demonizing
anybody those who would demonize us
are the problem
good could we crowdfund a large-scale
rct regarding the health impacts of
long-term prophylactic use of ivermectin
in healthy adults
yeah that's one possibility it's it it's
one possibility i think people need to
realize how much
money you would be talking about to do a
large-scale rct
and this is not our area of expertise by
um
neither neither running rcts nor nor nor
grants but i've been led to understand
the they're very expensive the order of
magnitude is something like
20 million bucks for a large rct so yes
could somebody do
it they sure could but it's a lot of
money that's a lot of money yeah
uh will ivermectin interfere with
substances like liposomes or phytosomes
or other medications like ace inhibitors
or
cyp3a4 inhibitors that last thing i
don't know what it is
well i think there are two things we can
say about this yeah one
is welcome to complex systems
you have no idea what this could
interface with in principle it could
interface with just about
anything yeah will it right what i would
say
is the overwhelming
safety profile the fact that this
drug appears not to be disruptive across
a huge
range of circumstances says your chances
are better than they might be
right so something about the way the
drug functions
seems not to be causing huge numbers of
problems except in you know
cases of for example people who are so
thoroughly parasitized that the death of
their parasites causes an issue
and so that's one thing we see but yeah
um
but they're look they're just no
guarantees right you're talking about
introducing a compound
that is not endogenous to the body into
the body
in a it's a complex system
period and so yeah the only the only
thing
one can say is your chances are probably
better with this molecule because
empirically speaking it doesn't seem to
interfere with lots of essential stuff
that's right so grateful to have found
you
thank you for your care your love and
your courage i think you may have just
addressed this but how confident can we
be in the vares data
well there's a paper um that i talked
about last week
uh that was this is the paper that was
looking at the first 250 people
who were entered in the ver system and
then also died and they were looking at
you know whether or not they were as it
turns out
none of them were coded as vaccine
deaths and they were all coded as covet
deaths which was
somewhat suspect um but as part of that
research those authors
uh found i forgot i don't remember the
numbers but it was something
north of 50 south of 75 percent um
where they were totally confident that
the day that the entries were made by
healthcare professionals and then
another like five percent or something
that was
made by pharmaceutical person i think i
think i think
that's right um so it's sort of like a
side note in that paper
uh where they said actually you know at
least a
large majority of these data we can
reliably ascertain
are are legit um that's the only piece
of
information i have um you know there are
people
there are people arguing on both sides
of this you know it's it
it isn't reliable because people are
going to be
you know want to put in bad information
because they want to promote the
vaccines because they want to
de-promote the vaccines and um you know
both are possibilities
but uh at least from that one that one
analysis suggested that at least most of
the data are good
well i would i would do the analysis a
little bit differently
i would say and i'll just speak
personally i don't trust the vares data
at all i don't think that system was set
up
in order to be a proper data collection
mechanism
certain things seem to be true in an
average
year it seems to be a dramatic under
collection of relevant information
it is also true that you cannot just
simply assume anything in that system
is correlated that the system will
collect a certain number of
events that are unrelated to the
vaccines in question
however to the extent that the system is
anything
it is a mechanism for detecting an
anomalous
signal of harm there is
an anomalous signal of harm could that
have another explanation
of course somebody could have you know
some economic competitor could have
arranged for such a thing does that show
up in the study you're talking about no
it does not nope no way for it to
no way for it to but the point is
what is the right thing to do when faced
with a system
that under counts and is there for the
express purpose of detecting
an adverse event signal when a massive
signal shows up
the right thing to do is to assume that
that signal means something until proven
otherwise and we are not doing that
so um how reliable is the data
i would say not reliable how
unusual is it how conspicuous is it how
inexplicable is it that a signal as
powerful as this one would show up there
and it would cause
no response it's almost
impossible to imagine this signal is so
strong that it needs an explanation
and if that explanation is anything
other than vaccine caused harm
then it should be an urgent priority to
figure it out and in fact i would point
this out
the incentive to find another
explanation
if there is one for that adverse event
signal
is so great that it is rather like the
pressure to find a population of
carnivorous in china somewhere
that has some sars-ko v2 ancestor
and the failure to have heard a credible
alternative explanation
is conspicuous that's good that's very
good
i mean it's terrible but it's terrible
yeah but i mean look
no but the logic is perfect we in the
public are entitled to presume something
is wrong to the extent that there's a
massive signal there it doesn't appear
to be triggering anybody to do anything
and it hasn't generated a
cogent alternative explanation right so
what that means is the onus is now
on those who are so sure it doesn't mean
anything to explain how
the hell that could be yeah instead of
brandishing
things to get people to shut up yeah
information on covet and preventatives
is so confusing and conflicted by design
maybe
where can we find honest information and
resources
yeah you know we're trying to do that
and um
the scientific literature is a mess but
there are some good
there there is some good stuff in there
which we try to bring some of it
um but you know that
there are some voices out there who are
trying to do this and it's
hard because of censorship it's hard
because of censorship and it's hard
because
you have no i there's no good way to
apply a standard that would allow you to
know
this is good this is who's a shill right
and you can discount a shill
and who actually has an honest
disagreement and so what i can say is
where you have um
the possibility for profit
you have to raise the question of
whether or not there's a corruption
yeah so that's that is to say you should
be more wary where there's a large
profit to be made than where there's no
profit to be made
and then within the category of hey
there's no profit to be made or this
person
is clearly not in a position to make
that profit then the question is well
um how uh how
committed do they apparently seem to be
with respect
to following the evidence where it leads
correct the mistakes
um but no there's you know i think the
question to ask is not is there some
place to go for reliable information
there isn't
why isn't there that's the question
obviously everybody wants a reliable
source of information on this topic
and the answer is to why there isn't one
has to do with
somebody having an incentive to disrupt
every attempt to produce such a thing
because the
obvious opportunity for anybody who
managed to produce such a thing would be
so great
yeah on balance i think the quillette
article was not well received by its
readers or by rebel wisdom
also is heather an intj in myers-briggs
yeah i'm
struggling for a connection between
those two i think it's i think it's just
two things
um yeah that i mean yeah the quillette
article
was nonsense and
anybody who knew enough about this
landscape to go through it and just
even spot check it figured that out yeah
so
um i think also uh
the response
of yuri
has actually explained a lot his
unreasonableness
shows up so potently in his interactions
with the public on this topic
that you know it's it's easier to
understand
why the article is so bad um i've seen
less from claire brelinski in the
aftermath of the article
so anyway yeah it is interesting um
do the data coming out of israel and the
uk potentially confirm vandon bush's
suspicions about mass vaccination during
a pandemic yes and no yeah that's what i
was going to say
yeah you have to be super careful
because there's a confound in there
which people have pointed out
which is to the extent that you have a
highly vaccinated population it's not so
surprising that
you know a large fraction of cases would
be amongst the vaccinated
right right so uh it is not you know
people
broadcast these headlines oh 65 of cases
are amongst vaccinated people but
there's but
one of the other results i actually know
much less about the uk but um
also in israel um a very high proportion
of the cases
um are i think it's delta variant so
like that you know that
that feels even more closely aligned
with uh van bush's predictions
potentially it's a little harder
but it's still because we don't know the
origin story of delta but
um the fact that it does seem to escape
from the
immune surveillance in initiated or
induced by the vaccines
is conspicuous so what i would say is
i i haven't seen
the proper study to evaluate
vanda bush's hypothesis as compared to
its competitors
yeah but superficially speaking we are
seeing a proliferation of variants they
do seem to render the vaccines less
successful at preventing them
and that is all uh loosely consistent
with it at the very least
so it is predicted at one level but i
would like to see
better better evidence
more rigorously evaluated and in fact
what has happened is
the dismissal of garrett vandenbush's
hypothesis has set the stage to fail to
evaluate whether or not it's right
which is obviously unscientific yep
off topic and maybe out of your
wheelhouse but do you have any opinion
on
kangen water i've never heard of that
but then parentheses low acidity
beneficial or snake oil so um
yeah i've run into this alkaline water
right you're gonna it's gonna be high on
the ph scale
um i actually don't know what high on
the ph scale means with regard to water
you mean how high yeah it's like is are
we talking nine are we talking 12.
nine okay um so
you know you know it's basic basic water
yeah um you know i've i don't i don't
know i haven't thought through what the
potential physiological mechanisms would
be
uh a few people who might otherwise
respect
tremendously on issues of health and
wellness
swear by their alkaline water and
um swear by it meaning they think it
does what
uh they think it improves their sense of
wellness and i like i'm sure if i asked
them
um i could get more more
precision than that but uh
they they love it they find themselves
drawn to what they find themselves
wanting it when all they have is uh
normal sort of
ph neutral or slightly acidic way i
think generally like city water tends to
be slightly acidic maybe like
you know high sick something like this
maybe i'm wrong about that
but um and you know but but just because
you're used to it
and just because you want it might only
mean that's because you're used to it
all right i don't know i'm gonna riff a
little bit here do it
one thing out in nature
i don't recall any instance of feeling
slippery water
but have you had alkaline water this
this is not so that
i have and the water that's being
bottled now and sold and you know maybe
the snake oil and just you get to charge
twice as much whatever
um isn't so alkaline that tastes
slippery it's not slippery no
okay i'd be curious as to whether or not
there's any
bias toward alkaline water in the wild
yeah it is possible so if there is not
then i would say
you don't inherently want alkaline water
though it could be that some novel
feature of our environment is
compensated for
by alkaline water so let's say the metal
in the pipes
you know could create an acidic
environment
i'm just off the top of my head i have
no reason to think this is true but
if it did create an acidic environment
then you dump a little alkaline water on
it it tends to neutralize the acid
and the base come together they make
more water and so you restore you would
restore in that way
the neutrality the neutrality yeah and i
would say my guess here
is that it's a corrective to hyper
novelty
well if it works at all i'm not yes i'm
not yet compelled that it does maybe it
does i don't rule it out there's
obviously mechanisms that it could
but the other question is as as we went
through
with um the issue of
medical finger wagging about salt intake
right yeah so doctors have been wagging
their fingers at us over salt forever
and the
basic punch line to the salt story is
that we're really good at regulating
salt because it's something we've been
doing
one asterisk right the one asterisk is
if you're cooking your own food or if
you're eating at a restaurant that is
cooking all of its own food
yeah you're really unlikely to be taking
in too much salt
if you're eating processed foods which
are covering
for the rankiness of a bunch of
industrial processes
by adding flavors in sort of
reductionist forms afterwards
and um and salt is an enhancer of flavor
you may well be getting way too much
salt in your diet and you don't taste
the salt because there's
it's it's just this like pieces parts
thing that isn't really food in in such
things so sort of the longer shelf life
of the foods that you're eating the more
likely you already be getting too much
salt
right that's that's the biggest there's
also then a question of what the impact
of that is and the body is actually
pretty good at regulating
levels of salt even that even even that
but like really if you're cooking at
home
you're cooking at restaurants that
actually make uh make their own food
and um and you're adding salt liberally
and you know your
spouse or whatever is like oh stop it
with a salt like you don't need to
probably not yeah yeah um so the
question is
is acidity also a parameter that to the
extent that your physiology is off
um it is very good at correcting for and
now i don't know people
get acid reflux and stuff like that
which is liable to be i know that i had
acid
acid reflux until i discovered that i
was
eating something that i was intensely
allergic to wheat
yeah at which point it completely
cleared up the point i eliminated wheat
from my diet so
um i don't know whether or not
my instinct says this isn't liable to be
a thing
naturally it could be compensating for a
novel phenomenon
but i remain to be convinced good
um would martian mushrooms be nutritious
poisonous so adjustable yeah
indigestible
um and the reason for that the reason
for that is because
you don't have the mechanism in all
likelihood to process something
mushroom-like
that you know i mean look you can't even
eat a tree unless there was a single
origin for life on earth and mars
right but even in which case it is so
long possible
yeah it's barely possible it's barely
possible if they share a basic
information molecule but okay so
nutritious no because you probably won't
be able to break it down at all
right yeah poisonous well it could
disrupt your system in the same way that
you know
uh you could get heavy metal poisoning
from
eating inorganic stuff so there's
something about it that could interface
badly with your physiology but
the reason that mushrooms are toxic or
so many mushrooms are toxic
is because they are trying to dissuade
things that would eat them from doing so
and so they built molecules
that interface with the physiology of
things that eat other things in a
disruptive way
and so the mushrooms on some other
planet are not going to have produced a
toxin that's going to interface with
your physiology because they don't know
anything about your physiology they've
had no history with creatures like you
so
yeah i would say you should look at a
mushroom on a foreign planet more or
less
like you would look at a rock on a
foreign planet and don't ingest either
okay we must be well over an hour at
this point
okay um we're gonna do uh one more
unless um yeah maybe we'll just do
we'll do two more all right we'll do two
more does the nature of the lambda
variant suggest that sarsko v2 is
mutating to beat vaccine defenses
see trial site news article on study
i don't i've not seen this and i don't
know anything particular about the
lambda variant
do you i mean i feel it feels to me like
um
like the presence the rise of the
variance
um is evidence in that direction but
it's not clear how strong that evidence
is
yeah i agree okay
and then this one can you correct oh
actually there's also
actually two just comments before i get
the last one sorry to hear your cat
meowing today i think he's missing his
little friend
he definitely is and um
will the book also have an audiobook
version who's the narrator we're
actually doing this next week
and at the moment the plan is for it to
be both of us simultaneously
yep we're going to alternate sentences
if not words
and then last question can you correct
for dysbiosis with fecal transplant
interesting question that um that that
question
is addressed in one tiny little
paragraph these papers that i was
reading from
um that i'll put in the show notes a
couple of them are really
quite expensive they got hundreds of
references so i obviously did not chase
down
all of them by any means but there is
some evidence that in some cases
yes fecal transplant can work um the
question though
would be how do you keep your you know
microbiome going how do you keep the new
the new microbiome healthy and intact if
you're not constantly getting fed from
your environment yeah well you could
look it up in the appendix
wow you know good actually
yeah i think we're done that was good
that was good
you get points for that one all right
now i got points yeah you'll know why i
get points for that one
when you read our book it will explain
that pun if you don't get it already it
will it will indeed
all right well uh we are done for today
we are done for today um please consider
um joining us at either of our patreons
uh
and subscribing to any or all of the
four channels the two on youtube the two
on odyssey this main channel that you're
watching on right now
uh and also the dark horse podcast clips
channel
z on both odyssey and and youtube
um what else am i supposed to say oh the
uh the clothing oh
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
and what else like like and share
like and share like share subscribe
spread the word yeah the whole thing yep
and
you know say it you
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
you